we are going to see the duchess
celebrate her 40th it is a milestone
birthday it's an important birthday and
i think there will be a celebration but
i think it will be a celebration for
family and for close friends and there
was talk of a of a big party which has
apparently been downscaled because of
covington because of the restrictions
kate will obviously be getting cards um
phone calls probably video calls from
family and friends over the weekend and
of course many of them will be sending
gifts as well and given that kate
arranged for gifts to be sent to archie
and lilly but over christmas i'm sure
the duke and duchess of sussex will be
sending a card and messages of good will
for kate on her birthday and more likely
than not i'm sure
a gift will be sent from la to london
obviously the relationship has come
under strain not just the relationship
between william and harry and but of
course between
kate and megan and casey and harry and
it hasn't been easy it's not made any
easier by the time difference an ocean
between them and of course william and
kate haven't yet met lily burton it's
been many many months since they've seen
archie i believe there are video calls
that take place not not particularly
regularly but there is contact i think
the relationship certainly between the
brothers is is strained and and remains
quite fraught and a difficult one but i
think behind the scenes throughout all
of this kate has tried very much to be a
peacemaker to try and bring the brothers
together and i'm told that she is the
one that arranged for presents and cards
to be sent to la for the sussexes over
christmas so i would be very surprised
if there wasn't um a card and probably a
gift sent
from the sussexes to kate on her
birthday i think in many ways that the
departure of the sussexes did leave a
big hole not just in royal family but
almost on the public stage and
you know i think many people thought
that with harry and megan leaving that
would be the end of the fun and the
glamour and you know everything that
people love about the royal family
and in fact it hasn't been and it's been
largely down to kate and i i think that
the royal family is still as popular as
it is people respect her they look up to
her they admire her she's very much seen
as a role model and i think certainly
over the last 18 months we've seen more
of the real kate the person behind the
title the hrh duchess of cambridge than
we that we have done
actually ever the plans for the
2022 jubilee celebrations are absolutely
going ahead and overcoming weeks we hope
to be learning more details and about
this four day event but the focus is on
on the queen on the queen being you know
well and absolutely able to take part in
those celebrations i certainly think
we're going to see kobe permitting more
travel being undertaken and the royals
representing the queen both here in the
united kingdom and overseas no monarch
has ever celebrated a platinum jubilee
this is an incredibly important event um
and and one that the queen
is very keen to celebrate she's very
much looking forward to the jubilee
celebrations um but there are you know
there are some hurdles to get past
before we get to those celebrations i'm
sure there will be an opportunity for
harry to come over during the platinum
celebrations this is a really important
milestone for the queen and one that she
will want to share with all of her
family um so there is a lot of
speculation as to whether the suspects
will all come over whether prince harry
will come over on his own will they be
up on that jubilee balcony and the these
are all things that have yet to be
discussed and decided as those four day
jubilee celebrations are are finalized
but planning is underway the jubilee is
happening and the most important thing i
think for the court is planning it is
that the queen is is fit and well and
looking forward to them
[Music]
you